c'est rien ça et les verts eelv atteint
par unilever pour aller le chiendent
tout va bien sûr tout va bien il est
franchement ça passe mais c'est rien du
tout bagnole ça passe mais chéri on a
beaucoup de choses à faire dans cette
émission on va parler de la sphère
bigard on va faire un point c'est sûr
parce que je suis allée fait appel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nicolas et benjamin ont rigolé
gbadamassi
on va faire avec elle et s'il vous plaît
déchire et qu'on se calme on appela que
cela soit déjà testé les cours puisque
les caisses collections les deux à
nantes et à l'écrit ou de salon on a
beaucoup de choses à faire on a beaucoup
de choses donc on doit parler m je me
vois pas donc je vais rien je suis allez
peut-être un peu fort mais